today on the matt wall show the vmas
were last night it was vulgar and
debauched and also boring and nobody
cared about it i think there's an
important lesson in that which i'll
explain today also george bush gave a
speech on 911 which has the left
celebrating him bush went from hitler
incarnate to one of the good ones what
does that tell us and white liberals
keep calling larry elder a white
supremacist plus a new poll shows that
democrat voters consider trump
supporters to be a bigger threat than
the taliban or china and finally many
people in the media have been defending
the vaccine mandates on the basis
that they in the media have the right to
be free from covet is that true does any
such right exist we'll discuss that and
much more today on the matt walsh
now we check in again with our very good
friends over at charity mobile and i
love telling you about charity mobile
because listen a lot of you people out
there you're
paying money every month to a mobile
service provider big company that um
either doesn't doesn't care about you or
or actually they probably actively hate
you and are
working against you why do that when you
can switch over to charity mobile and
it's so easy to switch and you will not
regret it other mobile service providers
are neutral at best when it comes to the
causes you care about but charity mobile
partners with you to automatically
support the pro-life profile maturity of
your choice with 5 of your monthly plan
price charity mobile
makes it easy to switch you can keep
your existing phone number and you may
even be able to keep your existing phone
it's very easy to do
but if you do get a new phone they've
got 5g phones available as well and a
lot of other perks new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
when you mention offer code walsh
there's no contracts there's no
termination fees and no risk with a
30-day guarantee they've also got live
customer service based right here in the
usa creating jobs in america which is
also really important so switch to
charity mobile and support a company and
causes that you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh
so the vmas aired on mtv on sunday night
i know what you're thinking wait the
vmas are still the thing and i know what
else you're thinking wait mtv is still a
thing i was just as surprised as you on
both counts i only know that this event
occurred last night because i read
through dozens of news articles every
morning as part of my job
and in my scavenging i stumbled across a
few articles
listing the winners of the um 2021 vmas
if you're curious and you probably
aren't the winner for video of the year
was montero by lil nas x
the one where he he twerks on satan
mtv giving its highest award to a video
where a gay man dry hump satan is
probably the least surprising
development of the year justin bieber
won artist of the year his 27th straight
win in that category i assume the trophy
for best collaboration went to doja cat
featuring
scizza
sza i have no idea who those people are
or even how many people they are but
apparently one of them came on stage
dressed like some kind of
nightmarish sea cucumber so that was
interesting
but the most shocking thing there there
there she is
that is uh that's dojika is that dosha
cat or sizza i don't know
looks like maybe uh maybe one of those
worms from the movie tremors
but the most shocking thing about that
outfit is that it covers more than three
percent of her body
many of the
other celebrities i'm assuming doja cat
is a celebrity decided to show up and
see through outfits thongs and so on and
so on um the performances on stage were
in keeping with that theme a woman named
chloe writhed around on stage twerking
slapping her butt in front of a giant
blinking sign that said booty so big
now that was downright subtle in
comparison to
somebody named normani who sang her hit
song wild side i'm assuming it's a hit
song while rubbing herself against
another woman who was strapped to a
bondage board meanwhile lil nazex
strutted the red carpet doing some
cross-dressing uh some sort of pant suit
slash dress combination and there was no
shortage of of politics to punctuate the
debauchery sydney lopper who evidently
is still alive
took to the stage to present an award
and then rant about abortion rights
and speaking of the elderly community
madonna was also on the scene she walked
onto the stage wearing a giant coat and
then dramatically uh stripped the coat
off to reveal the skimpy leather
dominatrix outfit and thong underneath
i'm not going to show you the thong part
i'll i'll have some mercy on you but
there's there's the outfit
now this is when you know that it's time
to put nana in a home
you can make the argument that even
allowing her to wander on stage looking
like that is a form of elder abuse
she even looks kind of you see there in
the in especially in the picture on the
right she looks kind of dazed and
confused
she doesn't know where she is
she has that sort of uncertain facial
expression that joe biden has made
famous we can only pray that biden
doesn't ever appear in front of cameras
dressed in a similar way
but at this point anything is possible
and now i've just pictured
biden in that outfit in my head and i
want to cry and yet in a certain way
i'm glad that madonna showed up and
stripped off her clothes
because there's something sort of
profound and emblematic about it
here she is an old woman
having long since run out of things to
say
and ways to shock and offend
reduced to simply
stripping on camera in her
late 90s
begging for our attention
it's not offensive so much as sad and
pitiful dull
you don't want to yell at her about it
you want to give her a coat and a bowl
of soup and pat her on the head and say
it's okay you don't have to do this
anymore
grandma sit down you'll be all right
let's put let's let's just watch some tv
murder she wrote is on i think
madonna in that way is a good
representative of the whole event and of
the broader pop culture that she helped
to create
there was last night plenty of
debauchery and perversion and nudity and
all kinds of desperate sexual
attention-seeking and none of it managed
to make any waves at all
the vmas ratings have been collapsing
for years nobody cares
you only know about any of this because
i'm telling you and i only i only know
about it because i read a couple of
articles just so that i can make the
point that i'm making right now
madonna was relevant back during a time
when
pop artists could simply wear revealing
outfits and sing about sex and um that
was enough to create controversy and
drive
publicity you know she could
roll around on stage in a wedding outfit
singing about losing her virginity
that was a big moment that was
revolutionary wow
but now pop stars can hump each other in
bondage gear while singing graphically
about their genitals and it goes
unnoticed
they have to go to greater and greater
extremes to generate the sort of hype
that madonna could once attract with a
fraction of the effort
you know lil nasek speaking of him got
some of the attention that he hopelessly
yearns for when he made that twerking
satan video but that controversy died
down pretty quickly and everybody moved
on and that's why he has to dream up new
degeneracies every week just to stay
within the vicinity of the limelight
last week he was
posing for pictures
while wearing a fake pregnancy baby bump
and uh and that was supposed to be
a thing
but even that's pretty boring and
standard these days especially in a
culture where millions of people
actually believe that men can literally
get pregnant
there was a time when it was considered
revolutionary and rebellious to be a
vile vulgar pervert
the perverts were rebelling against a
culture that rightly disapproved of that
behavior they were seeking to tear down
moral standards and structures that they
claimed were oppressive and restricting
and they succeeded the perverts won
but the thing about staging a revolution
and winning
is that now you are the man you're the
system you're the very institution of
power that you once sought to destroy
so you stage the revolution and you win
now you have to take over and run these
things that you were just five seconds
ago trying to tear down
so now the vulgar perverts aren't
rebelling against anything at all
madonna is old enough to be the
grandmother of most of the rest of the
people she shared the stage with
that means that as they were bumping and
grinding and showing their asses and
shouting look at me look at me
they were behaving exactly as a woman
their grandmother's age once behaved and
still does
there's nothing revolutionary or
shocking about it it's mainstream it's
acceptable
it's boring
it's empty it's feeble it's pathetic
of course this kind of stuff has always
been empty feeble and pathetic it was
empty feeble pathetic back when madonna
was doing it 30 years ago and everybody
thought it was revolutionary
but decades ago people made the mistake
of thinking that artists quote unquote
who showed their butts and sang about
sex were doing something brilliant and
and significant simply because it was
rebellious
now that it's no longer rebellious the
shine has worn off and it's easy to look
at it and think wow these people really
just have nothing at all to say
i'm bored what else is on
this is perhaps the most underrated
aspect of living in a morally decayed
culture
because if you didn't know any better
and you weren't living in such a culture
and you thought about it you might think
well
that could be fun at least
that's not it's quite boring
i mean it's many other things as well
but it's certainly boring
as it turns out evil has a rather bland
flavor
now the good news is that amid all this
dull hollow decadence
virtue becomes exciting and rebellious
i mean pop stars can spread their legs
and take off their clothes and scream
about their right to kill babies and
none of that is remotely revolutionary
or brave but if one of them had appeared
on stage to speak in defense of the
unborn
or to promote chastity and modesty
or even to defend something like
patriotism
that would have been truly shocking
and required real courage
it would have been a revolutionary act
none of them have the spine for that or
the value system so it didn't happen yet
the fact remains that the moral code
these people fight against
is the moral code of today's true
cultural revolutionaries we are now
the guerrilla warriors fighting against
powerful institutions who despise us and
seek to destroy and oppress us
it's not a good situation to be in i
would
not prefer it if i was given the choice
but it does provide an opportunity to
connect with people especially young
people who naturally desire to rebel
against systems of power
so we can say to them join us that's our
side
the rebels we're the rebels
or you can join the naked grandma on
stage to defend
the boring status quo
now let's get to our five headlines
if you're a pro-lifer and
you are firm in that position and you
know that you believe um
in protecting babies from being murdered
in the womb
but
you haven't thought deeply about some of
these issues and you haven't equipped
yourself with all the arguments
necessary you know if that's the
category that you fall into
then uh it may be maybe it's been tough
over the last couple of weeks as
abortion has been back in the news
because of the texas law banning
abortion and maybe you've found yourself
in conversations with pro-abortion
people
maybe they've thrown some arguments out
out at you you know we're wrong but you
don't exactly have the language to
navigate through it and sift through all
of the nonsense if that's the case
that's why you need to get the new book
what to say when the complete new guide
to discussing abortion that's from our
friends over at 40 days for life just
became an amazon bestseller and it's
number one in its category upon its
release two weeks ago very easy book to
use and reference it tells you what to
say and what not to say when abortion
comes up it has proven arguments that
have worked with everybody people on the
fence abortion supporters even planned
parenthood workers have been have found
these
these arguments compelling and 221 of
them have left those ways behind because
of the work of 40 days for life so you
don't want to miss this go to amazon or
get it directly from 40 days for life at
40daysforlife.com
okay so um
i got to say just a quick note here i
i'm speaking of decadence and and
decaying cultures
i am very glad to be
back from all the traveling we've done
over the last couple of weeks and we've
been in i don't know six or seven
different cities um
and i could not be happier to be home
because
the cities that we've we've been to it's
not like i've you know i it's not like
it's my first time going to some of
these these places but
most recently we were in new york
and my god
it is just a garbage dump
who could choose to live in these places
gross
just gross gray dull everything smells
everywhere you go
this is this is the case in uh in new
york there's definitely a case in los
angeles san francisco
uh everywhere you go
it's it smells like urine and weed
everywhere
and crackheads walking around the street
everywhere you go
and then and then to top it off
everything is is you know three times as
expensive
so that's that's the reward you get for
living amid all of this
misery and despair and garbage and crime
every time i go and i've always felt
this way about you know these bigger
cities especially new york
hadn't been there in a while this is my
first time back in in a few years it's
way worse than i remember
and i've always thought this and
especially now i think
how could anyone prefer this
if you think i love living in new york
it's it's got to be because you've never
been anywhere else
there's no way that a that a human being
that a psychologically stable person and
maybe that's the qualifier here that
that matters but there's no way that a
psychologically healthy person could
actually prefer
that
over living in a place where you have
grass and trees
and space
and privacy and quiet
and
you and
the smell of like nature and
you know fresh air
rather than urine and fecal matter
there's always someone could look at
that and say no i i prefer
i prefer the dystopian hellscape that's
that's that's what i prefer to be
horrible you got to get out of these
cities if you live there you you really
don't know if you're still there i have
to assume you literally don't know what
you're missing
all right um
let's go here number one president bush
speaking at the uh the flight 93
memorial in pennsylvania of course the
20th anniversary of
9 11 was on saturday and he was giving a
speech he made a comparison between the
9 11 terrorists
and violent extremists at home comments
that almost everyone has assumed were
referring to january 6th and trump
supporters but here he is let's listen
and we have seen growing evidence
that the dangers to our country can come
not only across borders
but from violence that gathers within
there is little cultural overlap between
violent extremists abroad and violent
extremists at home
but then there's disdainful pluralism
in their disregard for human life
in their determination to defile
national symbols
they are children of the same foul
spirit
and it is our continuing duty to
confront them
now
you know i saw the conversation on
social media and some of the headlines
that bush had
used his speech to attack
you know to mention january 6th the
attack trump supporters
uh and i listened to it and i
i didn't actually i was expecting him
based on the commentary i was expecting
that he would directly mention that and
he didn't that's all that's all he said
uh the assumption is that he meant that
as a slam on the right basically which
maybe he did i i don't know i mean it's
it's possible he wasn't referring to to
them
but that's the assumption
that certainly the assumption of the
left and the media
has a jump to here
and so they're they're hailing this
speech as courageous and so important
and everything this is this is part and
parcel of what we've seen when it comes
to uh to george bush over the last
uh over the last four or five years
specifically once
because there wasn't a whole lot of this
during obama's tenure
um but once
donald trump was in there
suddenly there was this newfound respect
that uh the media had
for for george bush
and it could be easy to forget and in
fact depending on how old you are if
you're younger
you may not remember some of this uh you
may not remember very vividly but i do
you the the way that the media talked
about donald trump for four years
they said the same things about about
george bush
it was maybe it was a little bit more
intense against trump but really not
that much more
because when you're comparing the
president to hitler and saying he's a
genocidal dictator
it's hard to have stronger or more
strident criticism than that and they
were saying that about george bush
for eight years they said that
and now uh and now they and now they
respect him and they say well gee that
bush he was he was so he wasn't so bad
was he
and so it may seem
impossible to you now you may not be
able to even fathom this but there will
come a time and it may not be that far
off
when they're gonna be doing the same
thing with with donald trump
i know it seems there's no way
given everything they've done
to trump and said about them over the
last half a decade but there will come a
time
when they're going to say in fact we're
already starting to hear that a little
bit
we we played the clip i think a couple
weeks ago someone on some cable news
channel said well when you compare
trump to a desantis i mean dissent
trump is not so bad compared to desantis
so whoever the most recent guy who
whatever whatever republican is in
office or whichever republican
uh there they consider be the biggest
threat
then all other republicans in comparison
to that one are you know
were
were innocent in comparison
so that will happen and all that means
is that
you know we say that the left respects
bush now or whatever it's it's not
respect it's not love it's not
admiration
uh
it's of course it's not sincere it's
just that bush is now useful to them
it's a useful comparison for them to
draw
and when he criticizes trump or trump
supporters
whether explicitly or not
that's even more useful
so they will quote respect you when they
feel that they can use you and that's
what they're doing with bush now
and meanwhile i wish that uh
honestly i don't know why bush is being
invited
to speak at any 9 11 memorial
i i don't want to hear from george bush
one of the most disastrous presidencies
in american history was george bush's
presidency
i mean the the irony here is that
many of the criticisms
not the overblown dramatic he's hitler
and all that not that
but there are plenty of criticisms
levied against george bush during his
tenure by the the media that they were
they were right about
and now they're the ones
haven't been proven proven right on the
on that not that you can give him credit
for it because he's a republican so
they're going to criticize him
and it's a broken clock thing it just so
happens that they're going to be correct
sometimes
um especially because there are plenty
of bad republicans out there
but now they're the ones going back on
that and say oh george but that george
bush
he's a lovable guy
look he does he does his watercolor
paintings look at this cute old man
george bush
all right the the surgeon general on cnn
is now saying that actually businesses
are relieved that they're being forced
to mandate vaccines so there's nothing
to complain about here businesses are
are happy that they're
being saddled with this mandate
according to the surgeon general
the requirements that we just heard
about are one part of that but they're
only one part of that includes also
measures to increase our testing
capacity to shore up our hospitals and
healthcare systems which are struggling
with delta but what the president would
all of us have said as public health
leaders from the earliest part of this
pandemic is that we have to use every
lever of government
and we all in the private sector have to
do everything we can to tackle this
virus the requirements the president
announced are an example of that
earlier in the summer the president had
announced requirements for federal
workers to attest a vaccination and this
is another step in that direction not
only will federal workers now be
required
to vaccinate with an exemption for
medical or religious purposes but also
bus you know health care systems that do
business with medicare and medicaid 17
million health care workers will be
required 80 million business workers who
have you know 100 employees or more will
also now be required uh you know under
the osha rule uh which is in process
either get vaccinated or get tested
regularly so the key thing to understand
dana is number one the data tells us
that these requirements work to increase
vaccinations number two a lot of
businesses
are actually relieved that these are
going into place and we've heard a lot
of feedback from the business roundtable
and others that this will help create
safer workplaces but finally dana keep
this in mind this is what we've got to
do to get to the next phase of this
pandemic response so that we can get
through this and get back to normal
it sounds ridiculous
and it is
except that you could you could qualify
it this way
he there's there's one one qualification
he forgot to mention
forgot on purpose i'm sure
uh what he just said is probably true of
big
big businesses mega corporations
they probably are relieved because it
takes the problem out of their hands
and now they can force the uh the
vaccine on their employees without
having to worry about getting sued or
anything it just it just takes out of
their hands and now
uh it allows allows the government to
solve that problem
and they're big so they can deal with
the turnover if they lose a bunch of
employees they can deal with that
they have the capacity to deal with it
small businesses it's a different story
they don't have the capacity
to enforce these mandates
when you drive employees away they don't
have they don't have the capacity for
that
um to to pay the what is it fourteen
hundred dollars
per
per violation that they're going to have
to pay
um
so this this again this is this is
something that affects small businesses
big businesses are fine
small businesses are the ones that carry
the bag on this
there's just there's never been we've
never seen anything like this
this conspiracy by
the most powerful in our society
to utterly destroy small businesses
that's the other thing you see when you
travel around the country as i have done
not just in the last couple of weeks but
over the last year and a half
and everywhere you go
everywhere you go
you got the walmarts and the targets and
mcdonald's and they're all doing fine
but you find shuttered smaller
businesses
boutique type shops smaller restaurants
everywhere shut down
and it doesn't matter where you are
smaller towns bigger cities
and you you know you talk to the locals
they all have the same story oh that
place over there they used to be a great
great place we all used to you know
and now it's gone shut down during covet
hasn't come back
but all
meanwhile the government's
handing money out to people
uh welfare payment hand over fist
so the money was there to spend it's
just all that money is going to uh the
consumers have the money and they're
spending it it's just it's going to
amazon and it's going to walmart
this is a conspiracy to destroy small
business
and it has worked we've never seen
anything like it before
still on the kovid topic here's fauchi
on a podcast called skim this that's the
podcast never heard of it uh advocating
for vaccine mandates for kids and for
air travelers i think is the first time
he's been this explicit about it here he
is
if we get the overwhelming proportion of
the population vaccinated we will get to
hurt immunity if we do it in the next
six months it will happen in the next
six months if we do it in the next two
months it'll happen in the next two
months i would support that if you want
to get on a plane and travel with other
people that you should be vaccinated
when you
hear us say should you mandate
vaccination for children to be able to
attend school
some people say oh my goodness
that would be terrible to do that but we
already do that and have been doing that
for decades and decades i don't know
what school you went to but the school
that i went to you had to be vaccinated
for measles mumps rubella polio or
otherwise you couldn't go to school
so it is not something new
i have to say again kids are already
vaccinated against covet
you know you know what their vaccine is
called
it's not pfizer or moderna it's called
their immune system
their immune system
provides kids better protection
than what is provided by the vaccine to
adults
so a child
who was unvaccinated is less likely to
get seriously sick than a vaccinated
adult
that is how significant this protection
is for kids that is given to them by
their own biology by their own immune
system by their bodies
so they're already
vaccinated that's the difference we keep
hearing the same point over and over
again well we have these other vaccine
requirements
not all vaccines are are the same
first of all with some of these other
vaccines
all of the other vaccines that he just
mentioned they've been around a lot
longer
so we know more about them
about the side effects about the
long-term effects
if there are any negative long-term
effects to the vaccine for kids if there
are
we how could we possibly know that until
years down the line from now
there'd just be no way to know that for
sure
but more to the point those other
diseases that he mentioned
are especially hard on kids
and that's why you could make a
compelling argument
for inoculating kids against them
covet is not
thank god it's not
it's something we could breathe we
should be breathing a sigh of relief
about i i have this entire time
as a parent i am extremely thankful
you know what if if kovid
was as dangerous to kids
as the media pretends that it is
if that was true it was actually as
dangerous as they're saying that it is
for kids
then my my own personal calculus would
completely change
because i do believe as a society we
have a special obligation to protect
kids
i mean i believe that
there's a lot of these people in the
media who are pretending to be concerned
about kids
when it comes to anything else they're
not they're not they don't care about
protecting kids but i think that's true
so if this kid if if this virus was
affecting
kids the way that it affects say the
elderly
then that would probably entirely change
my approach to it
but it's not
and that's a great thing
all right a white la times writer by the
name of gene guerrero had some thoughts
about larry elder which
uh she decided to share on on cnn and
we we've we've heard this exact line
many times
and they're pretty shameless about it
but here it is let's listen he's
essentially been running his campaign on
fox news and on right-wing media outlets
um he he's refused to talk to
large you know to non-partisan and media
outlets and to journalists who are
critical of him
has refused to answer difficult
questions often uses uh the few
interviews that he does give as an
opportunity to give a performance on on
social media you know denouncing those
journalists and um playing the the
victim um but he has been able to reach
the the minority of voters in california
who embrace his his white supremacist
world view um and you know he's he's
co-opted this line by my fellow
columnist uh from from the headline you
know calling him the black face of white
supremacy but he refuses to
engage with the actual substance of our
reporting you know the idea that he his
his
views were shaped by a well-known white
supremacist named jared taylor who he
repeatedly quoted in early writings um
that he plans to reverse all of the
state's progress on immigrant rights and
racial justice um and that he poses a
very real threat to communities of color
for all of the reasons that we've
recorded it in the past
just a just another example of of how
white supremacy has become this doesn't
of course doesn't mean anything at all
it's this
religious it's this religious idea um
this
sin that you know it actually goes
beyond white people
if you have the wrong ideology then
you're automatically a white supremacist
and it's important to remember this too
because um
you have to kind of adjust the equation
on the
on the uh the victim
hierarchy the victim pyramid that i've
talked about before
we know there's a a hierarchy of
victimhood on the left
and uh and there's always this jocking
for position that goes on
and the the group at the top tends to
change over time
uh i could change even on a monthly
basis as there's this struggle to who's
going to be the the uber victim
and as it stands right now
top of the victim of pyramid the victim
hierarchy are trans people
and specifically uh trans people of
color they're the very you you cannot
get more victory than that they're at
the very very top
um and then as you go as you go down the
ladder
there's really no one challenging trans
people right now for top victim spot
so they're pretty comfortable
they might not be there forever but
they're pretty comfortable at that spot
right now
um and then as you go down the ladder
for the different victim groups
that's where the positions tend to
change it gets pretty interesting
but that said
there is the ideological qualification
here which is really important
so normally larry elder as a black man
would be uh pretty high up on the victim
hierarchy like above women
there was a time not long ago and that's
why i say things change during the me
too movement the women had their time in
the sun as the uber victims and they
were the very top probably even above
trans uh and now they've fallen
precipitously
so
you know normally you would say and we
know that
on the victimhood pyramid pyramid
criticism can only go down
okay someone who's lower on the
hierarchy as a victim cannot criticize
anyone above them
trans people at the top they can
criticize everybody
criticism can only go downhill right
um so normally
a white woman
attacking a black man in this way
would not be acceptable
but
that's where the ideological
qualification comes in because he's a
conservative none of this counts
conservatives are at the very very very
bottom of the ladder and once you get
down there
races identity none of that matters
they're all white supremacists they're
all nazis that's all
so that's the way that's the way this uh
that equation works all right this is
from
says 57 percent of democratic voters
believe supporters of donald trump are a
serious threat to the nation a scott
rasmussen national survey found that 56
of those in president biden's party also
consider the unvaccinated a serious
threat that's a higher level of concern
than democrats expressed about the
taliban 44 percent see it as a serious
threat china or russia
uh so
trump supporters are
greater threat than the taliban and
russia and i i give that
has context
which brings us to to this a point that
bill maher made on his show last night
and of course it's upset a lot of people
which bill maher to his credit is
willing to do he's willing to upset
people on the left and here he is
explaining why he often criticizes the
left but he says something about
the the black national anthem which
they're now singing before football
games they sang it before opening day on
thursday night
uh and he has some thoughts on that that
some people on the left are upset about
but let's listen
people say to me sometimes like boy you
know you go after the left a lot these
days why i'm like because you're
embarrassing me
that's why i'm going after the left in a
way you never did before because you're
inverting things that i i'm not going to
give up on being liberal this is what
these teachers are talking about that
you're taking children and making them
hyper aware of race in a way they
wouldn't otherwise be i mean i i saw
last night on the football game
uh alicia keys sang lift every voice and
sing
which now i hear is called the black
national anthem now maybe we should get
rid of our national anthem but i think
we should have one national anthem
i think when you go down a road where
you're having two different national
anthems
colleges sometimes now have many of them
have different graduation ceremonies for
black and white
separate dorms this is what i mean
segregation
you've inverted the idea
we're going back to that
under a different name
now the points he raises there are are
good points and i'd like to agree with
it that we shouldn't have two national
anthems
you know we should have i don't agree
with this point whether we should get
rid of the maybe we could get rid of the
national anthem that we the real
national anthem but we should only have
one
um
i think i think our national anthem the
national anthem is uh
is
is good i'm i'm i'm happy with it
uh it's worked for us
and i think it could continue to work
but
his point
that uh well you know we should just
have one because we're one nation
i wish that was true
but it's really not
i mean if anything
uh we should have
50 different national anthems
at this point
because we're so fractured and broken i
mean there is not one united country
anymore
so the fact that we're now having
multiple national anthems that is a
reflection of a reality i don't like it
i wish it was not the reality i very
much wish that it wasn't but it is
you know that's that's something that i
struggled with on uh on saturday as well
with the the
9 11
anniversary and you know i just had to
stay off line and not watch any news or
anything
because when i hear
people and in these moments still
talking about hey you know this is a
we think back to that day this is why we
need to come together as a country just
like we did on 9 12 right after 9 11 and
there was unity and yeah we all talk
about that i remember it too
i can remember that period of time
which in reality was probably only a few
months but there was definitely a period
of time when there felt what it felt
like we were united as a country
that's what it seemed like most of the
fighting and everything had been put to
the side
but now when we talk about that i mean
it just sounds
sort of sad and pathetic
it sounds to me like
someone
some broken old person reminiscing
when they were in their prime in high
school and how they were the football
you know
they were the quarterback captain of the
football team
now those were the good old days
yeah maybe they were but uh they're long
gone now and they're never coming back
you know if something like 911 were to
happen again something really like 9 11.
not january 6th which was not 9 11 but
something actually similar to 9 11 or
worse were to happen now
we wouldn't have that 9 12 effect
there wouldn't even be
six minutes of unity
not even close to it
we're not one country anymore
and that's why the scott rasmussen poll
democrat voters consider republicans to
be the greatest threat to them
doesn't surprise me either
those are the kind of poll numbers you
see in a country that has come apart at
the seams that is not one united country
anymore
because as i always talk about you unity
you cannot have unity for its own sake
that's why the unity on right after 9 11
didn't last it was nice
it was emotionally cathartic
and and it felt sort of emotionally
healing
but it didn't last because it wasn't
real
it was kind of unity for its own sake
nice in the moment
but what are we actually unifying around
there has to be some kind of unifying
principle
now in many other countries across the
world
um they have a shared heritage
they have they have uh you know
in many countries they have shared
religion
shared
race racial identity you know that's
that's the case for many countries
across the world that's never really
been the case in our country
so what do we unite around
if not any of that
then it would have to be unity around
shared principles and shared values
which is a nice idea
to have a country united around
something like that
these higher ideals
and there was a time when we were but
we're not anymore
does
we all we all love freedom no we don't
we all have a shared uh passion for
human rights no no we don't
we're united around our sense of
equality i don't even know what equality
is
we certainly don't have a quality of law
equality anywhere else doesn't exist
so we are many nations and i thought the
same thing going back to when i was some
of these other cities that i that i'm
kind of
touring and looking at in horror and
thinking how can people live like this
i don't recognize this
i don't want any part of this
and i i can't relate on any level to
someone who's like this is this is their
ideal society
so where do we go from there uh i don't
know i think eventually we
we go into pieces
fun thought let's get now to our reading
the youtube comments section and um
we'll start with this let's it's been
pretty heavy let's get let's have some
good news i think now we finally have
some good news and um i can announce
after a week of of build-up i can
announce the winner of the sweet baby
gang anthem contest and the winner is
walsh's anthem by joshua waythan i
thought all five contestants
were phenomenal
and i i want to thank them all
deeply and and sincerely from the bottom
of my heart
because i know the
the the talent that they put into those
songs in those videos
and the emotional energy i feel that
emotional energy as well
uh so thank you for that all of them
were wonderful but i thought i do think
that this song is a deserving winner and
let's all for the first time now on the
matt wall show
experience that song together here it is
[Music]
who makes a twitter mob fly off the
handle with rage
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
who's rocking polka dotted flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
baby gang
[Music]
this theocratic
dictatorship is on its way daily
cancellations
[Music]
dictatorship is on its way daily
cancellations
[Music]
well there it is and get used to that
song because you're going to hear it
every single day now
that is our anthem
i don't know
i don't know the national anthem we have
a bunch of different national anthems
now that is our anthem and we will all
stand with our hands on our hearts and
listen to that whenever it plays and i
expect you to do that by the way every
time i play that song now
i don't want any kaepernicks there's not
gonna be any kaepernicks in the in the
spg gang
if you're on the internet right now
which
uh many of you many of you are
then and you have not taken steps to
secure yourself then you are vulnerable
right now just by using the internet
that's why you need life lock
researchers have determined that email
phishing attacks and brute force attacks
are the two most popular and successful
methods cyber criminals use for
ransomware and extortion attacks on
corporate networks these attacks are
simple to attempt difficult to detect
and can come with big rewards for cyber
criminals that's what makes it so
dangerous it's important to understand
how cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
it really mess your life up good thing
there's lifelock lifelock helps detect a
wide range of identity threats like your
social security number being for sale on
the dark web and if they detect anything
like that they that something's been
compromised they will send you an alert
and they will work to get it rectified
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25 off your first year by
going to lifelock.com walsh that's
lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
let's now read the uh the comments
brandon says fat phobia who's honestly
scared of fat people it's not like it's
hard to run from them
brandon that
that that's not acceptable though that's
juvenile
it's not funny
how dare you brandon
we don't we don't partake in those kind
of juvenile insults on this show we
don't do that
i'm not going to ban you from the show
though for it
uh maybe that gives you an idea of my
real feelings veronica says since we're
becoming a dictatorship anyway can we
just have matt take over and rule with
an iron rod
at least his rule would be logical i
totally agree veronica thank you big boy
says matt i was a submariner we didn't
dress formally just to be locked in a
metal tube
um i'm going to just wear normal clothes
on an airplane don't be silly as long as
you're presentable and hygienic
who cares
well
maybe we don't have to go all the way to
formal clothing but it's more about the
environment it's like the message that
that sends to people
okay it's not that
i necessarily have any objection to
sitting next to someone who's wearing
jeans
but the point of the dress code on the
airplane is yeah number one to stop
people from wearing pajama pants
stop them for wearing sand sandals even
even uh even shorts
okay i don't want you in shorts sitting
right next to me on the plane i've got
your your hairy sweaty leg is rubbing up
against mine i don't want any part of
that
so that's one reason for the dress code
but also it's about
sending a message of the kind of
environment it's about kind of classing
up the environment
and i think it makes people when you
dress nicer
you behave better psychologically
i don't know if that's actually true but
it's my theory
um
ojh says i don't know matt i'm 25 and
your planned evening sounds ideal to me
too maybe it's just an introvert thing
not an aging thing however although
although general so's chicken is my dish
of choice at chinese places too i
recommend indian or thai takeout next
time you want to change it up once
you're on the phone with the indian
place it's too late to
wuss out and order the general again
yeah i agree with you that it is a
that's kind of how i guess you could
define whether you're an introvert or
not
the evening that i had planned for
myself that i mentioned on friday
i had the whole
had the you know had the night to myself
my kids and wife weren't there
and my idea anyway was just to order
food and sit in a chair and read a book
and that's and go to bed early that was
like my that that to me would have been
the ideal night and that sounds ideal to
you it's a pretty that's a pretty good
indication of introversion which is not
the same thing as shyness a lot of
people don't understand that
not the same thing as being shy it's
just about where do you where do you
find your energy
you know what's what's the most ideal
setting to you
all right andrew shelley says matt as
the head of the household you should
take a leaf out of the leftist playbook
and begin indoctrinating your children
into the sbg get t-shirts
um baby girls etc for them sbg forever
that would cause problems you cannot
imagine in my house so as it stands
right now my children have not been
indoctrinated into the sweet bed again
called i mean one of the reasons is that
it would feel very weird to me to show
my kids uh a
shirt of of me in a in a diaper so that
there's something i think
psychologically for them that wouldn't
be the healthiest thing
um
and maybe when you think about it
if i wouldn't even want to show this
shirt to my kids should we be selling it
is this whole thing just way too bizarre
i mean that you might arrive at that
conclusion i don't know
but i've told you how my wife feels
about it so
that would cause a civil war in the
house if i tried to if i tried to do
that i'm not ready for that yet not
ready to have that battle yet maybe one
day
and now we get to do our daily wire
promos everyone's favorite part of the
day as the legacy media continues to
spread propaganda in extremely
precarious times it's important that you
have a source you can trust that's why
the daily wire created morning wire the
daily morning show dedicated to bringing
you all the news you need to know
without any spin or hidden agenda it's
the only daily podcast that values your
time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to make sure that
fact-based news still has a platform we
need your help to keep it trending
towards number one so subscribe and
start listening now to morning wire on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts and leave a five-star review if
you like what you hear
what's happening in america's day is the
antithesis of freedom this is a new
promo sorry uh new promo our president
has decided to go to the authoritarian
route and mandate vaccines for all
businesses with over 100 employees which
includes us here at the daily wire but
we're not standing for it we're fighting
the mandate for our employees for our
freedom and for you and we're pretty
fired up about it that's why you should
tune in to catch an all-new episode of
uh us discussing this issue and so many
others on backstage tomorrow it'll be
myself
ben shapiro jeremy bourne michael
knowles and andrew clavin it streams
tomorrow at seven o'clock eastern 6 pm
central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel dailywire you don't want
to miss it now
one more thing now that the new sweet
baby gang anthem has been crowned you
can grab the official sweet baby gang
shirt that represents the spirit
of that anthem which you just heard uh
you you can you can have it
in your heart that's what the music does
it
it fills your heart with warmth and
gladness and you can also wear it around
to show your pride as expected they're
selling out fast so click the link in
the description to get yours today it's
it's a masterpiece this is a limited
design so if you're
you know a long-time member of the sweet
baby cult you're going to want to snag
one if you're a new member
you're going to want to you know and you
want to really show your loyalty because
it's very important to us in the sweet
baby gang then that's all the more
reason to go get the shirt again the
link to get your shirt is in the
description below wear your sweet baby
gang tee with pride now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
i said last week that it's troubling to
see all of these people most recently
howard stern who are now marching under
the banner of f your freedom
some members of the covet cult are now
quite open and shameless about their
opposition to freedom they're explicitly
calling for your freedoms to be abridged
or destroyed
and
they want you to be oppressed in this
way for their own sake and they're very
clear about that i said this is a
disturbing development in our culture of
course
uh there's nothing new about the fact
that many people don't really care about
freedom at all what's new arguably is
that so many people are willing to admit
to it
to come out and say
f your freedom
and i still think that this marks a new
and terrifying stage in our societal
decay but i must say that the eff your
freedom crowd
annoys me a little bit less than the
people who are still pretending
that they support vaccine mandates and
masking laws for the sake of freedom
this has been especially common talking
point on cable news
for example new york times health
reporter sheryl stollberg appeared on
msnbc this weekend to argue that in fact
we are not taking away your rights by
forcing a drug into your body rather
by not taking the drug you are depriving
her of her rights
i'm sorry to be to to be course about
this but there are hundreds of thousands
of people who are dead
because they did not take the vaccine
what i mean the science is playing out
before our eyes
right so a couple of things about what
the governor said first of all in an
infectious disease outbreak getting
vaccinated is not a personal choice it's
not it's something that we do for the
community and this has been long upheld
with legal precedence second of all the
governors who are complaining about
biden's mandate failed to note that he
in fact gave business as an out their
employees can opt for mandatory uh
weekly testing and third he talked about
well there's a long history with those
other vaccines well how do you think we
got that long history we got that long
history because the vaccines were
mandated
and she was not the only one um at the
new york times to strike this chord
david leonhart made the exact same
argument listen to this
i mean there are two ways to think about
freedom right one is does someone have
the freedom not to get a vaccine shot
that's a legitimate question the other
is do we as americans have the freedom
to go out and know that we are less
vulnerable to a deadly virus that is
also a form of freedom and that's why i
think that the sort of pro-freedom case
for vaccine mandates is actually
stronger than the anti-freedom case
americans deserve the freedom to go to
school without fear they deserve the
freedom to go to school without health
risks they deserve the ability to go to
football games and go to broadway plays
and the long history of vaccine mandates
shows two things they make a lot of
people mad or at least a small
percentage that often translate to a lot
of people in a big country and they save
lives and i think that is the likely
effect of these vaccine mandates they
are going to push a whole bunch of
people who weren't getting vaccinated
before to do it because otherwise their
lives are going to be really
inconvenient um and they're going to
save lives
okay let me answer uh the first question
for you david do we as americans have
the freedom to go out and know that we
are less vulnerable to a deadly disease
no
we don't have that freedom
we don't have that right in sheryl
stohlberg's phrase to not get killed by
an infectious disease that rate doesn't
exist
that is not a right that exists it can't
exist
you don't have the right to be free from
infectious diseases for the same reason
that you don't have the right to be free
from osteoporosis or asteroids or shark
attacks
these are all risks that come with being
mortal creatures living within a natural
reality that we cannot control
if infectious diseases infringe on your
rights what or who is doing the
infringing granted a person who
intentionally infects you with a disease
intentionally
may be reasonably accused of infringing
on your rights just as you could say
that your rights are infringed if
somebody physically throws you into a
shark tank
but aside from direct and intentional
acts of biological terrorism sickness
and disease are an inextricable part of
life
to say that you have a right to be free
from these risks is to say
that you have a right to be free from
the basic facts of reality
you may as well jump out of a window on
that on the basis that you know you have
the right to be free from gravity
this confusion is probably
why
and and this is going to sound maybe
surprising we should all stop talking
about the right to life
or talk about it at least in a qualified
and more specific way
even in the pro-life movement
now this is going to seem like heresy
but in fact
you don't have any sort of universal
inherent right to life
to say that you have an absolute right
to life is to say that whenever you die
no matter how you die
it's an infringement on that right
the problem with abortion is not that
the baby has a right to never die
nobody has that right of course
the problem is that the parents and the
abortionists do not have the right to
intentionally destroy human life
what's more the parents have a positive
duty a positive responsibility to care
for their child
abortion is a rejection of that
responsibility through an act which no
person has the right to perform
that's why i've long said that i think
we when we talk about the pro the
pro-life case
um against
abortion we could talk about rights but
we should really be talking more about
responsibility
do parents have a responsibility to
their children or not
they do
and that's a that's a better and more
precise and more clarifying way to speak
about uh about the right to life the
right to life shouted as a broad and
unqualified mantra with no other
specifications to it tends to lead
people to the conclusion that even
nature itself
owes them immortality but you're owed no
such thing
it's not my job to make sure that you
don't get sick
okay i was not born with that obligation
that that's not a that's not a that's
not a responsibility that i have to you
as a stranger to make sure you never get
sick
you're not owed that the old the world
doesn't owe you that
you're not owed safety either
or the feeling of safety
because that's something that the david
leonhardt said
well do we have the should we have the
freedom to know
and he may as well have said to feel
that when we go out we're going to be
safe from infectious diseases
and that's really what they're talking
about
the right the freedom to feel safe
but that's not something that you're out
either none of that comes with the
package when you enter into the this
world it's not on the brochure
and if it was on the brochure the
brochure lied to you you need to get a
new travel agent
the good news though
is that you can take whatever
precautions you want
on your own accord of your own will and
volition
to grant you freedom from covid
is not my job
it's not the world's job
it's not your neighbor's job
it's not the government's job
but it was supposed to be the vaccine's
job
okay no i don't get the vaccine to
protect you
just as you get the vaccine to protect
me you get it for yourself it's supposed
to grant you protection
and if you really believe in the vaccine
and you trust it
and you trust the science behind the
vaccine
then you have already granted yourself
that protection now because you have a
right to it
but just because it was available to you
and that's a precaution that you chose
to take
and that is your responsibility not
anybody else's
and so for that reason
those two people on cnn and everybody
else talking about their right to be
free from covet or free from infectious
disease they are all today of course
finally canceled
and we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by sasha thomashove
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily
dailywire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show former
president george w bush speaks at the
911 memorial in shanksville and compares
the january 6th rioters to the 911
terrorists joe biden's surrender to
al-qaeda continues on 9 11 and democrats
turn to internacion warfare over their
3.5 trillion dollar budget buster will
get to all of it that's today on the
bench bureau show